[Applause]
after winning applause for a successful
first plunge last week NASA's Cassini
spacecraft will conduct another dive
between Saturn and its rings this
afternoon the mission has given
scientists the closest look at Saturn's
atmosphere astrophysicist and Hayden
Planetarium director Neil deGrasse Tyson
says Saturn is his favorite planet I
guessed it aside from the earth his
newest book is astrophysics for people
in a hurry it offers a pocket-sized
primer of our understanding of universe
Neil deGrasse Tyson good morning thanks
for having me back guys
oh yeah yeah so tell us about this dive
and your favorite plane scene he's been
up there for a dozen years orbiting
Saturn and you can't last forever and
it's time to finish out its mission and
to do this it will it will be taking
death spirals down that's what it is
what can we learn what are we going to
learn well so it's the first time we've
ever sent a spacecraft through the plane
of the Rings right in between Saturn the
ball and Saturn the ring so initially
there was some concern about particles
that would damage it but it survived
just fine and we're going to keep doing
this until September when it takes its
final plunge into the atmosphere where
it will vaporize never to be seen again
we encourage people to look at the sky
and quote ponder what cosmic truths lie
undiscovered before us ponder for us
well what I try to do I tried to collect
some of the most mind-blowing science
astrophysics in this in this small
volume it's a curated selection so
there's things you've heard about you've
read about you've reported on dark
matter dark energy exoplanets multiverse
it is all there and I try to tie a bow
on it at the end with a cosmic
perspective where such as the image of
Saturn what one of those images
portrayed earth yeah in between that's a
cosmic perspective like the pale blue
dot the Carl Sagan's is the thing about
God the more we learn we're more likely
to find some kind of life on another
it's that's a that's driving a lot of
people's ambition as we look into space
especially in the search for exoplanets
so I have a chapter called exoplanet
Earth where I get to think about earth
as
there were aliens trying to figure out
if there was life on this planet we call
earth when viewed from a distance and
this gives you some insight
it's what as to what our challenges are
as we look beyond you are a rock star in
your world kneel view listen they call
you geek cool you've got 7 million
Twitter followers and you say I wake up
every morning and wonder how's that be
cool every day universe is under no
obligation it makes sense to you but you
do say it's important to know physical
laws because they can give you
confidence they can give you power and
you tell a very simple story about hot
chocolate Deena California I like hot
chocolate yeah and I order hot chocolate
with whipped cream of course and it
comes and I don't see any whipped cream
and and the end and the waiter says yeah
we put whipped cream on it it just sank
to the bottom and I said ah no unless
the laws of physics of the universe are
different in your restaurant no whipped
cream on this I'll show you and it
brings back and puts in a doll and it
bobs once or twice and there it is a
float yeah this this batch he put on top
and they're saying you're that guy yeah
yeah yeah don't try to tell me and the
rule he should have known oh well no so
here's something that's a little
counterintuitive that thick heavy cream
is lighter than milk okay yeah so that's
why it floats no and you leave us with
this more bacteria live and work in one
centimeter of your colon than the number
of people in the world know the number
people have ever been born who have ever
been born reason why I report on you
know everything you thank you for that I
don't know why need to know that but
okay why is that important oh okay
cosmic perspective doesn't always have
to come from the universe come from
chemistry it can come from biology and
it's it's in a cosmic perspective put
you put us in our place in the universe
and people can think that means you feel
low but this this comment about the
bacteria in your gut if you think you're
at the top of the evolutionary ladder
and you're in charge just ask those
bacteria because they're thriving in as
far as they're concerned you're a dark
anaerobic vessel of fecal matter for
them okay and if you if you just if you
get them upset you will know very quick
I've never thought of you as a dark by a
fecal matter No
the lower-intensity neither that's where
they thrive so it's a it's a way to say
no you're not really in charge as much
as you think you are Neal you got your
first telescope and you looked in it and
you saw what you were 9 yeah we know I
was at a planetarium at age 9 and then
aged 12 I had my first telescope did you
see that it fascinated you so that today
you're sitting here yes I saw Saturn for
the first time as yes it has rings and
you can see them in the moons and you
come back subsequent nights the moons
are in orbit and so this this is a an
endless frontier and what I think of and
I was attracted by how much we didn't
know more than how much we do know and
that's where the Wonder and the mystery
gets fulfilled and served speaking to
that what's the great likely most
important discovery to be made in your
world well so we have so the James Webb
Space Telescope a follow-on to the
Hubble telescope that is tuned to see
earlier in the universe in any telescope
ever before so we've got we've got
missions lined up just to take care of
they went at night 9 now you run the
place yeah yeah that's cool thank you
somewhere we roll